jared lyons has been called her favorite
economist and can perhaps help us
understand her thinking he joins us now
i could see you smile though when i said
that you're her favorite did you see
that as a compliment or how do you how
does that go down that one
well i think economic policies are sound
so i would take that as a positive is
there much is there much that you
disagree with her on then or do you
think is it the direction of travel that
you do well lots of people are talking
about trust economics but trust
economics has yet to really be defined
so it's both what she says and also what
she does but i think what's really
encouraging is that she wants to really
address head on the immediate challenges
the biggest risk we currently face in
addition to high inflation is the risk
of a deep recession
and the two things that she has
highlighted that she will address in the
next few weeks the energy crisis and
also reversing the tax increases are the
two single most important issues to not
just ease people's worries about the
future but they're the two most
important issues to prevent that deep
recession the global economy is slowing
might be difficult to prevent a slowdown
but she's taking full action in my view
or will do to address that right so you
don't think that a recession is
inevitable
recession's not inevitable
look the two big issues as i say the
energy crisis by capping prices she will
take the risk away from people and from
firms
the government will take on the risk so
that's an important factor also it will
cap inflation and in turn inflationary
expectations and then in terms of the
taxes clearly if we went ahead with the
planned tax increases it's inevitable
that we would have a recession so coming
back to your question a recession is not
inevitable but the world economy is
slowing and indeed the markets are
reflecting that as well um you're
talking there about the need to act on
energy prices uh but also the need to
try and keep taxes lower as not raising
more
that surely means we're going to see an
awfully big increase in borrowing
the biggest threat to the public
finances is if the economy has deep
recession so that's what liz trust is
confronting straight on so therefore we
should be reassured about the public
finances and in terms of that the
borrowing if we look at the borrowing
figures the markets i think will be
reassured by measures on the energy
front that removes the worry about
growth collapsing i think the markets
will be reassured by liz trust or indeed
quasi-quite and the chancellor today
reaffirming what was already clear that
the bank of england remains independent
but more importantly coming back to your
question her fiscal measures are
necessary given the reasons i've
mentioned to prevent a downturn they're
affordable and they're non-inflationary
inflationary because of the nature of
our inflation shock our inflation shock
has been triggered by supply side
factors exacerbated by poor monetary
policy not everyone agrees with that
they do that some people do say that
cutting taxes or or
or cancelling proposed rise in taxes
would be inflationary the ifs for
example you know paul uh johnson now is
not the time for big tax cuts which can
themselves make inflation worse okay
right in terms of first the energy price
cap like two weeks ago goldman sachs
said that inflation would hit 22 percent
yesterday barclays said based on fixing
the price inflation would peak at 10
so that's a big difference also bear in
mind that the obr the independent obr
said that one percent said this back in
march one percent off inflation says
five to six billion pounds a year in a
full fiscal year so that's very
important in terms of the actual
inflation expectations component what we
need to watch is what happens on
monetary policy not just fiscal policy a
clear consequence
of what liz trust is planning is that
monetary policy will be focused on
kerbin inflation and fiscal policy will
be very much focused on stabilizing the
economy and tax cuts are not the
opposite end of the same seesaw as
interest rate hikes basically if taxes
go down that does not mean that interest
rates go up but interest rates will have
to go up as the markets have been saved
and indeed the markets were saying this
way before liz trust looked like she
would become prime minister just want to
talk to you a bit about the markets
because it feels like you know there is
a risk there you were saying that you
think the markets will be you know
reassured by some of the policies that
you don't think that higher borrowing
will uh lead to alarm but at the same
time it does feel like that is perhaps a
bit of a gamble i just want to have a
look at what's happening with the pound
as well because this is another part of
the story as well
uh i think i have to go do it this way
there we go
this is the pound falling i mean it goes
back to as you say and it's not just a
trust thing it's gone back like way back
to 1964 this this graph but it does just
show how low the pound okay do you
realize what the main story was in tokyo
this morning the weakness of the
japanese yen 30-year low the euro
recently is an all-time low the key
story here is the dollar it's very
interesting one because the last time
the dollar was this strong was august 85
and then what we had was something
called the louvre accord stabilization
amongst
all the big countries to stabilize it
what's more interesting for the uk is
what's happening to guilt yields and
that's an indication of borrowing now
guilt yields here 10-year guilt yields
are around three percent they actually
improve today the gilt markets so that
gives you an indication that the rate at
which the uk government borrows
yesterday they also hit a ten year high
the guilty fields yeah and also like
this is not just this we will understand
that the dollar is is strong at the
minute but this is about more than just
the strength
let's get back to borrowing rates
because uk government borrows at a
cheaper rate than the us government also
the maturity of our debt is twice as
long as the maturity of german
government debt so that puts us in a
very good position also bear in mind
that as i said if the inflation outlook
improves that improves the borrowing
figures as well what comes back to this
is that the markets want to have
confidence about the policy no one
should ever be complacent about markets
i've been in markets for 30 years but
it's about explaining clearly what you
want to do so coming back to your
question on the energy crisis markets i
think will be reassured on that front
making the bank of england really take
stock of inflation is reassuring but
then the markets i think will take
comfort from a fiscal policy that's not
just going to stabilize the economy but
it's quite clear that debt to gdp which
is lower in the uk than the other g7
countries is on the clear downward trend
so it's fiscal discipline fiscal
financial solvency but the market's
clearly like it with anyone they'll have
to see what is actually unveiled and
that's the key thing it's pretty clear
that you are uh happy excited even to
see some of this trust's policies and
going forward um she said that she wants
to set up a panel of economic advisers
to help steer her policy are you going
to be on it well she said that the
weekend i don't know obviously is up to
the prime minister who's on it but he
would say yes
well depends on the terms of course but
the answer is probably yes but the
important thing about who who is on it
is obviously important but we need to
confront treasury orthodoxy since 2008
trend growth in the uk has been very low
the treasury says
growth is low more the budget deficit is
structural a decade ago they wrongly
used that economic thinking to justify
austerity which was wrong and in the
last two years they used the same
economic thinking to justify tax
increases what liz trust is saying let's
not be in a hole and dig deeper let's
actually ask why we can't get stronger
growth let's get stronger growth higher
wages and sustain what is pretty good
jobs picture at the moment so let's see
what she does i do think it's a sea
change in thinking and as we've seen
today she's quite she believes in it i
think the markets actually will give her
a vote of confidence if she does deliver
on what she has said oh well we'll find
out won't we in the months ahead thank
you so much for being on the program out
there jared lyons